hello, good afternoon, it is a pleasure to be able to
share this forum with you.
I am ibone 11 and I work as a
coordinator in the animal room of the
Universidad Autónoma Metropolitana on the
Xochimilco campus and my talk will be
the formation of bacterial biofilms
and why this is a latent danger  For
our facilities I hope you find
it useful and that you enjoy this
talk. Above all,
you can also
find biofilm called biofin or
bacterial plaque and we can define it as
communities of microorganisms that
grow in a matrix that is self-
generated, this is  very important because
they are capable of self-generating
polymeric substances that we know
as exopolysaccharides and that will
give protection to the colonies that form
these biofilms, these will be
attached to a surface, either inert
or to living tissue,
the bacteria exist  in nature
below two forms which are
bacteria which are plankton and cas  or
free-living and those found in the
fine biofilm in the biofilm it is postulated
that 99 percent of all
bacterial cells are in the
quality of biofilm and yet only
1% is in the Platonic state what is
curious is  that all human infections
are still based on
treatments and all these issues on
minority studies of 1 percent
in planktonic bacteria instead of
doing more studies on bioends
that's why I thought it was important
that we look at these issues
and they're going to  see in the bibliography that I
am going to present to you in all my talk that it is
more or less 10 to 12 years old 15
years old are issues that began, however,
later they are very old, not now with it has been
seen that in fossils
the violin was already present
as  the biofilm or the bio-
end is formed,
well, here I present a diagram
of
how it will be formed and I present
four steps at the bottom,
you can see how the phenoti is  type
of the colony this phenotype will vary
depending on the micro of the micro
ecosystems that the bacterium has,
so the first one is not the
Platonic bacterium that arrives and fixes itself
to some surface, either inert
or living, in the second step it goes  to be
the adhesion to the surface and
once the adhesion is given it is
irreversible in the third step we see the
maturation that is all the release of the
exopolysaccharides 3 see in this part
here how the
exopolysaccharides that are going to protect are already being formed  to
all this colony
and the formation of the quorum sensing that
later we will see what this is the
growth of the entire colony
and finally the dispersion of the
cells this dispersion can be in two
ways or the Platonic cells that
once again become the  cycle in a
new area or a detachment of
all the biofilm that also causes
this dispersion to colonize
other
substrates adhesion is very important
once it  it reaches the bacteria and
adheres to the substrate that we have already seen
can be
any surface
this is totally irreversible the only thing
that it will check is that once there is
an abundant supply of nutrients it
can be attached to any surface as
we are going to see more  ahead and the biofilm
is conditioning what does this mean
that it conditions the environment and
we do not condition it albiol end and
the properties of quorum sensing that is,
in this part of the biological
conditioning there are certain genes that are
activated or repressed throughout the
development of the bacterial community
the consensus is the formation
of the matrix that leads to it we call it
our matrix of the colony and this will
regulate several functions such as
mobility not in the case of bacteria that
have a mobility system the
expression of factors  of virulence
the export for the bacteria that is
for úl in the production of antibiotics
that is going to generate this consensus and par
Because there is no room for other types of
bacteria, the exchange of
genetic material by conjugation, in addition to the
development of the biofilm,
the bacteria and other organisms that
use the formation of forum sensing
elaborate and secrete
signaling molecules that are auto-
inducers, and that is what I was saying.  on
certain genes that activate or
repress throughout the development of the community,
that is, the phenotype of the bacteria that
lives in these colonies is very different
from a Platonic bacterium and the
main molecules, for example, for
the great negative is cirh omo
scheringa  lactones and for the great
positives it forced them lost
in this scheme I want to show you how
is the activity carried out by the
colony in a biofilm if you see in this
part
asking or to change them in this
red part we can see that all these
bacteria are at rest without  However, the one
that is at rest means that
this is how the gene bank of the
colony is in this p  art will
save all the bacteria that later
if the other layers are attacked,
this layer of protection will always be maintained
after there is an activity that
is low in the next circle we see
that the activity is already intermediate and in
the green one we can observe  that the
activity is high and obviously it will be
high because this is the one that will be in
contact with the outside
and in addition to the fact that it will be in contact
with the outside
this is the one that will be able to form
dispersal colonies
the composition of  the biofilm of the
biofilm we can see that 95 percent
is water and only 5% are
microbial cells or their derivatives,
the bacteria, as I was saying, if they
synthesize their own matrix, they adapted
sens and it is the one that is going to be in charge of
doing all  the signaling and apart it will
give the instructions for
the exopolysaccharides to form but an
issue that is very important in the
colonies is how are these biofilms
contain water channels that pe  rallow
the transport of nutrients
metabolisms metabolites sorry and
and then point here and the
chemical signals that they secrete in response to
increased bone population density
they are able to regulate their
population density and make their colonies
dispersal and by themselves  out little not
everything that interferes with the development of
biofilm bacteria are capable of developing
biofilm on many
biotic surfaces look at this is a drinking trough that
was supposedly already washed
and when you take a closer look at how
the biofilm is here
that can escape  to the naked eye
, however, doing these zooms
we can see that it is already in the
violin formation and for people they may
think that this is already a drinking fountain if
you see in these parts the drinking fountain
is clean and yet in this one
where the  pacifier is forming the
bio fia
and well to this other example we can see
the pipes as they are  to the bio
file biofilm growth and this is
where drinking water will pass to
our animals so the ability
to bind to various plastics, crystals
and metals also depends on the
specific proteins of
the bacteria's coat and it has also been seen to
depend  Of those of motor apprentices,
for example, coconuts that do not have
news appendages have seen that it
has no effect and yet that it
can perfectly make a
biofilm
four factors I present to you to form
a biofilm and be able to enter an
organism
first to circumvent the defenses if  They give me a
favorable habitat because I will be better off,
I make the formation of my matrix and by
which a sense and forming an entire
community and I am a biofilm or a
biofilm
and as I was saying, a plan
tonic bacterium is totally its phenotype is
totally different from the  that lives in a
biofilm she has to change and
later we will see to the extreme
that she can get to t  ener in its changes
and well obviously if I am a
biofilm I can also form
dispersal colonies
I love this scheme because it was
presented in Nacho's magazine and it makes me
very exemplary of all this look
here it says putting together not waiting for each other
we will all be successful in this  quarter here and
see how it is here it says I am going to
have breakfast in my bed
finding a niche to grow and all
the signaling that is given
to be able to carry out the
dispersal colonies so how are the
dispersers well it could be because  a
platonic or free-living bacterium can
be leaving a part of the biofilm
towards the flow
that has not detached and
colonizes other areas or this third one
that rolls up and when it rolls up already
contains all the part that we saw of the
bacteria in  rest in less activity
more activity then all this
part that is coiling up can be a
dispersal colony
and obviously if it is in  some organ, well,
it can reach others and affect it or if it
is in an inert environment, not someone fomit, well
then the contamination will be
carried out by other committees
another interesting thing about
biofilms is this one presented by
doctor david davis and he  He also presented
in Nacho's
magazine where he tells us about resistance to
antibiotics and look how interesting to
describe
we have an untreated colony, another that
was treated after 20 minutes and 24
hours, and if you see, even if
the resistance of the antibiotic has been treated,  biofilm to
antibiotics results in
incomplete death and what
allows bacteria to maintain themselves and
generally these are the ones that
cause recurring recurring diseases or
chronic diseases and this because many
of you may have these cases that you
have not known to yourself
who gets a sore throat and takes
antibiotics and after a short time he gets
sore throat again and says no
I can believe because I take care of myself and take the
antibiotic and everything, but if you did not
eliminate this part,
it cannot be here, there is a focus
of infection to grow again and
re-form the colony,
another of the studies that the doctor did on me,
who is also  It is very interesting
how the antibiotic penetrated,
that is, if it penetrates the substrate
through the biofilm and the
exopolysaccharides,
and the antibiotic penetrates, that is, by
going through the biofilm, all it does
is
divide, forming more dispersal colonies,
that is,  the
situation worsens because what is forming
are more colonies and it is not a
localized focus but rather it is going to form more
contamination
so this antibiotics and the
resistance associated with biofilms
have also shown
that bacteria can neutralize the
antibiotic these bacteria that live in
colonies not the Platonic but those who
already live in the colony I told them how
certain genes are activated or repressed
t  All of this
because they can produce enzymes that
will neutralize the antibiotic,
penetration is also limited by
the matrix because when I know that we are
talking about a layer of
lipopolysaccharides that is very
forgiving of exopolysaccharides that is very
thick and that will give it protection
as if it were an extra layer, not
of a type of plastic that is going to cover
these bacteria, if it is an example of a
type, say a type of plastic, but so
that you understand me,
this persistence of the cells, not here, you
can see what a  genotype in
cells that are not replicating
because remember that we said that
the gene bank is located in this part
and there is no replication and they
maintain slow or no growth
here in this part there is a change in
active metabolism of oxygenation and
gradients  of ph to inhibit the antimicrobial action
this change of metabolism bacteria
that were always aerobic can
become anaerobic and in life
Platonic that it would be impossible to think
that a bacterium that has always been, that
is, I am not talking about bacteria that
are creative and that can be aerobic or
anaerobic depending on the type or the place
where they are reproducing, otherwise these
are bacteria that are totally
always.  aerobic but nevertheless in
this area they can change their metabolism
until they become anaerobic
so that they can see the importance and how great
this system is that of change and
how this biofilm can affect an infection in
this way
the film interferes with phagocytosis
and obviously  it interferes with
phagocytosis because it will also affect
optimization
if there is no phagocytosis optimization will
intervene
in regulation and there will be an
alteration of antigenic presentation,
that is, it is not that there is not
a  alteration but really what there
is is no presentation, be it cellular immunology
, it will be totally affected
because there is no  There will be someone presenting it,
the ex or polysaccharide is giving it such
protection that it does not allow
phagocytosis to take place, it does not allow
destruction and then there is no
presentation so that the cells could enter,
the cells of the NK cells,
etc., there is neutralization of the
antibiotics such as  We already saw it and as if that
were not enough, look how interesting that
studies have shown that there are
biofilms between fungi and bacteria
so if it were complicated to have
a biofilm of bacteria, it has been
seen that there are unions between fungi and
bacteria, imagine having a
respiratory disease
with not being there or streptococci not and
apart from a 1 a yeast a
candida for example not then well
this still the severity is going to be much
greater and obviously it will be a pneumonia
a fulminant pneumonia
brother
the magazine of public health of mexico in
in 2011 and the national institute of
health in 2013 told us that
75% to 80% of diseases
Bacterial bacteria intervenes in
biofilms, note how important
this data that we are
seeing where they are no longer making sure that
from 75 to 80 of the diseases
a biofilm has intervened, the formation
of the biofilm causes many chronic infections,
as I told you, for example
, throat diseases.
tuberculosis cake tuberculosis that has
taken a lot of strength with people who
have AIDS
also saw movies and then there
is the question of
chronic infections the pathogen
cannot resist the attacks of the
immune system or it protects itself according to
its  no protection layer and it stays there
happily and then aside from that the
protection it has is much less
sensitive to the action of
disinfectants and we want to disinfect
areas and also antibiotics
I had said that these can
grow on any surface  biotic
wow biotic and look at this picture shows us
a biofilm of staphylococci in  the
inner surface of a needle,
that is, the instruments in the
catheters, the filters, all of these are
foami tests, which are a dangerous source of
infection for all the
dispersion of these types, which
diseases are the most common,
the most common diseases, here I will
show you what  We are going to see all of them, but
I want you to see how many of them do not
become chronic and how
this system, which can be either due to
damaged tissue
or a foreign body
, has not been seen that biomaterial is a
contaminant, it is a source of
contamination  important in the formation
of biofilms and in the network
the bacterial violin is involved in
diseases in the case of rodents it is
not the same and we have this union that we see
that it is bacterial and fungi it is commonly seen
salmonella staphylococcus aureus
staphylococcus aureus and hella etc.
that hides  the clostridium
so that they remember what a biofilm would be like,
and it is clear that this
is already a very advanced case of u  A person
who has not had good hygiene, but
a person who does not brush their teeth,
does not know all night and all day,
you can see that the biofilm
is already forming, it is no longer there and you
can see it, it is the biofilm that is  It is
forming and it is
a form of dispersion that has also been
seen and that is why now dentists
recommend that you also have one that
is brushing the tongue that the tongue is
a biofilm contaminating factor and
look here how the biofilm is forming
and  Well, thinking about our
technicians, are they our veterinarians or
ourselves, since we are a source of
infection for animals, this is a
case of streptococcus pneumonia
in rodents, a severe respiratory
disease is seen in the animal and here
we see it, they put it in glass  to
take this micrograph
in chronic otitis media it is very common due to
staphylococcus aureus streptococcus and
mycoplasma
also in orchitis and if you see there are
some strains that  e we buy
in places that are supposed to
be free of any bacteria with
free of antibodies since viral,
not just the virus and not antibodies
and bacteria and yet they come with
staphylococci or with except a few and
we are going to see this again  these results
that the animals present orchitis
the tonsils the tonsils zone
as well as the favorites is like the zone of
to be maintained ended
then imagine that this
someone from your staff who was
working with animals and if you see the
formation of of these species that  They
call it the crater clinicians and there you can
see the biofilm formed, not because they are
dispersal colonies that this
person sneezing when coughing their hands all
this can contaminate and please see
the language also as it is with
this biofilm formation
here  I present an access if you see this
is the area of ​​the bacteria where there is a
greater concentration will be on the
outside and all the formation and  This is the
exopolysaccharides, this protection that
is perfectly done
in accessing
wounds,
look at the formation of biofilm in
that is, do not confuse what would be
healing and what were the pleasant
milestones that also look like a form
of filaments  but this is a filament
of elvio fin what is being seen in
this part how it is being formed
imagine the severity of this lesion
in an animal and how difficult it will be to
treat it
he saw fin it can also be found in
protozoa
and this is the case and  In other species
this is the case, for example, with
zooplankton, it
is the copepods, so the biofilm
remains inside it and when it comes to drinking
the water, what is going
to contaminate is going to be the bacteria from the
book Vibrio cholerae, so
these people are going to  to have cholera but
another important piece of information that you have seen if
you remember the vibrio cholerae, that
is, the bacterium that produces cholera,
has toxins, that is, they are toxins that it  it
releases and these toxins have been seen to
be related to its fibers, they are not
formed in the fibers and thus form the
colony contaminated with the vibrio
cholerae, apart from the toxin that is very
harmful in cholera, it is said that the
bacterium is not so  harmful as its toxin
that it produces
and so well here I also
present to you how the health sector, the who and
various international agencies
give people who have no other option to
drink more than this water because there is
no drinking water they give them this type  of
filters and also in changing them so that they
can drink and filter and not get sick
or they teach women
to filter with fabrics such as
cotton fabrics that can
filter and remove copepods to
reduce
cholera and biofilms as well  They are reservoirs
of pathogens and, for example, the flea
serves as a vector for the biofilm and is made
up of diseña pestis. Look here is a
non-colonized flea and look at how
the biofilm looks in our  zone
the development of biofilm in the flea
salt
it when taking the blood of the person or
the animal because obviously it will
contaminate the
because remember that they first
inject a kind of anesthetic to be
able to continue sucking and then they take the
blood hands hands hands  hands are
the most contaminating part that there can be,
there are hundreds of studies that
show us that hands are the
most dangerous committees that can be in
a facility and a hospital facility makes
a bioterium where
you want in a school the hands
contain  amount and well obviously if
I tell you this it is because they can also
have formation of biofilms from
different types of bacteria and the
person has a
sick throat well imagine now
that everyone and then on this hand there
is no greeting or how to grab hold of the
animals
Well, it's going to contaminate
here. He presented a study that
was
done where he put 10 at 5, 10, 12, and
10 at l  to 3
colony-forming colonies
in a unit catheter when colony-
forming units sorry this and
these were exposed in a catheter and
this kpc was placed and see in the
imaging studies how the development of
the infection of the animals looks depending on
the amount of the  area of ​​the millions
that have been placed in colony-
forming units
here is already seen
up close the implantation of the catheter
contaminated with it and the catheter that
is uncontaminated see the lesion there is
no access formation that
will burst due to contamination  from the
biofilm
so well I don't want to be so negative anymore
so I present this photo where it
says that when all else fails then hug
your dog and your cat so that at least
it gives you comfort and affection
this is because we are in the month of
love and  friendship and then, well,
taking advantage of it, then I'm going to
start giving them so as not to see all the negative things,
you talk to them again about solutions that
we can  We must have for this
to eliminate or not allow the
growth of these
biofilms so look at all the
factors that influence the quality of
the animals if you see I will make this
list for you and tell me where
the biofilm could not be in the drain  in the
cages in the staff, either there is an
external suit in the ventilation systems,
air conditioning and
heating, these are one of the most
dangerous in insects, we have already seen that they
can also be in insects, not the
water, so the biofilm is present
in all this
This aside,
although the talk, the interesting
talk by Dr. Benavides, did not tell us
that it was good, since between 80 and 85
percent are already using animals with
specific genetic characteristics, yes,
yes, apart from everything, we are
using knockout transgenic animals.
those who, by their
nature, are already immunosuppressed, this does not
complicate it, it will complicate more and we are going
to be much more careful  that if
we handle colonies that are
conventional and by their own
maize system they are not much more resistant than
a line with blood, not always some
in a strain that is not with blood, it
will be more resistant, not because it has been
uploaded to the hybrid, than a line  with
blood the importance of water is
vital if you remember I told
you that 95 percent of the
biofilm is water and 5% is
bacteria and their derivatives then
imagine the importance of water and if
this is drinking water  What do we
give them more importance, then
look at the biofilm, it is adhered
from the origin of the water, that is, it could
be in the treatment of
the filtration. Look here we see how
the biofilm forms or formed in the filter medium, it may be very well
filtered and yet a warehouse arrives
and is contaminated or all the
distribution systems look at this the pipe I
already showed you what a pipe looks like and
I am going to show you some other fo  cough from
the pipes contaminated by the wind
so we don't know where
the water comes from it can come from the
mountains it would not be from the deepest and most
beautiful and pure well that however we
don't know when the
transportation came from where that water was stored
or the distribution of it
look here is other data this is not
so severe but look at
how the saw end is found imagine the
contamination they have and the formation
of colonies of the millions
of dispersion colonies that they are going to have in these
pipes
to control what we have to do
, whether in a tissue or on an
inert or living surface, is to prevent
bacterial adherence eliminate the
biofilm that is already established it has been
reached if it has been established avoid
proliferation no that it does not continue to
proliferate no  continue to exist in the
formation of dispersal colonies and,
above all, alter the pathogenesis of
biofilm if and if we alter this
part, then we are going to  to find better
results in its control,
the main sources of contamination
are municipal water and the am warning device and
surprisingly later when I came to
give advice and asked them about how they
are treating their water they say no if we
soften it and now people believe  that
to soften them they are going to purify or
make the water drinkable and well, we sit down,
we have to use filter banks and
then some alternative system such as
ozone, osmosis, ultraviolet,
use of chemicals, yes, and what has
been seen works very well for
these  to have a better control is the
discharge or what they call the flushing
we do a discharge three
times a day that is programmed and thus
we avoid the formation of the biofilm
because the water will always be with the
ozone not working and it will not be  it is going to
stagnate and it is going to remain there
obviously
flushing systems have to return
the water to where it is being stored
so as not to waste and  l water because
we know that this is a worldwide problem
of water use and the amount
of water that we have
water pipe treatments
generally use oxidizing
systems oxidizing systems are very good such
as ozone hydrogen peroxide
acid and folklore bear and
chlorine chlorine dioxide but nevertheless we have
to be very careful with these
because being oxidizing we can also affect
the pipes and oxidize them and this is going
to give us contamination problems because
we are going to have leaks or corrosion is  that
can alter the quality of our
water generally what is recommended
is expensive but it is done once when
the installations begin is to put in place for
the
automation systems that the pipes
have to be built in a city it is expensive very expensive
and good  what do we do we do the
treatment but what we must take care of
because we are doing the treatment and
what we do is also the
detachment  ent in the biofilm and this
can contaminate more areas if they
remember the scheme they did not arrive, that is,
we can be releasing
electronic cells or bacteria the act to my
case of free life or we can completely release
a part of biofilm that developed
not as we see it in  In this scheme,
we have to be careful how to
do it and I am going to explain to you
how we do it. First, we have a
softener, after the softener,
we have a boat of filters, other
filters, and an ozone purification plant passes.
If the ozone purification plant is not
working, we have to  in turn
a dv lamp to guarantee them in a
form of ciu redundancy does not fail
we have another alternate system
because we chose ozone because as
I said they are systems that oxidize but
apart from killing any
spore and toxin organism
this I don't know egg
any
fragment that remains  also product
of some polluting agent these
also lead to oxidation  they can
oxidize and degrade this herbicides iron
magnesium
heavy metals and knots I was saying
toxins also sulfides from pesticides
because I already told you also in herbicides
etc. so if you see this is a
very good system that is also not
dangerous to handle because it is not
even handled happens  the water is nice and
then it is not like the management when
chlorine or acid products are used that
stain the tables stain the floors that
people can suffer burns
etc. if they do not have a good management in
this case there is none and also they do not know
You just spend nothing extra, that is, you
buy it from the start and you don't spend it again
on other chemical products, so
I think this is a good advantage.
I don't have to go a little faster. Well,
there are some who make a filter, something
minimal.
much more effective and then it goes
through reverse osmosis
and automation. I think it is one of
the best solutions to carry
out automation because the less
the hand is  the less man
intervenes, extra contaminations that we
cannot control will not be better, but
we must be careful, for example,
we have this system, it
is automated and we have to
autoclave the cages not to
avoid growth in the drinkers and in
turn  We put the entire rack
of animals so that all the
pipes are
also sterilized.
Well, something I did not tell you about and it is
important to me is how we manage the ozone
to clean the pipes. We
normally have 5.8
milligrams per liter ready
and when we want to clean the pipes
that we do it once a month because we take a sample from the
furthest pipe from our
installation and
raise
the amount of ozone to double or
triple and we test with
special tapes that show us that the
concentration is very high but in
fact up to  own smell tells us that
it is already very concentrated obviously
we disconnect so that the
animals cannot  We drink this water
and we clean all the
pipes that we have in the different
rooms to guarantee that there is no
biofilm growth and there is no
contamination. Sanitization is very
important, whether they are in
the automation stations or in
filling stations.
the change of vital filters
the changes more filters that I teach
these banks of filters that each one
is making more filtering the
periodic review of the filters 15 this filter
that is, this filter was already changed when it
is already a source of infection that is  Here
we are already guaranteeing that the
bio-end is happening after all that I told you about,
if we have this part, it
is already totally one
more contaminant instead of helping us,
the water filler
currently available
seems to me to be a very good technique.  It is a
development where
bottles are replaced by
sterile bags and the
pipette used is sterile and disposable.
We have this little one and
our pipettes are not disposable
but we can use the stone because they are made of
stainless steel. These bags, another of
the characteristics is that we can love them for
dinner and Cézanne and chalk, the box where it is
stored and Cézanne use the bags,
so here is the growth  of
biofilm it is
impossible for it to occur they are completely
sealed
sanitize and stabilize it
is very important and why because if
we encourage ourselves and sterilize
we cannot remove it I told you about how
the dispersal colonies are formed
so if you use and leave
part of the  colony that this is maintained
we can avoid it by sterilizing so
it is best to sanitize and
sterilize as much as possible that
the rooms with terminal hepa filters
are very important and why is this or
if good they do not have to be hepa filters they
can be 90  and 185 but it appears that he was
speaking to you that the
air conditioning and heating ventilation systems  action
are excellent social reservoirs
we are giving them darkness we are
giving them this is the chilean in all their
pipes in our facilities
and then the humidifiers arrive at the manager
so we are giving
what they want that we are giving
an age we are giving
them temperature we are giving them  all the conditions
for their growth and we
are injecting them into the rooms, not
for contamination, or else I don't know, they do
n't have terminal hepa filters,
well, the bio bubbles are a
very good system to eliminate this, or the
ventilated racks don't  that they also have
their own filtration and so it will not
depend on the filtration of the building
that we are injecting it
with.
So my best recommendation is to
sanitize your hands all the time, it
is not very important.  It is important to sanitize
because we have already seen that they tell us that
90% of hospital diseases
are due to
contamination and many of them and the
main one is all due to the hands and the use
of gloves, yes, it is also another technique
that is very important, it does not matter  The
number of gloves that many people have to use
tells me about my people who
work with me, and I
thank them for the support
they always give me.
without a white box and
then it's also the gloves, it
doesn't matter, you have to change the labels
that those five cages to contaminate a thousand
later because you didn't change your
gloves so how much they look at these
that few are even
purple we have them depending on the areas the colors
to know about  who who is
working in that area and so this is very
important many times we have to
use 10 pairs and it doesn't matter or it is
cheaper to use 10 p  Are you that a
massive contamination in our
colonies of animals that in the first place
keeping them is very expensive the production is
very expensive and this
and bringing them we have to
import them to the US because it is more expensive for us
well thank you very much I want in
these
these little minutes that  I am very
grateful for the
incredible effort
of Marcel Pérès to unite to call us
and ask us to work as a gift to
teach us this whole system of how to
do it, all the preparation, the
practices that have to be carried out,
thank you very much for inviting me and
thank you very much for  having
allowed him to enter his
facilities to give you this talk
if you have any questions
we still have a few minutes here
well thank the people who are
in my talk
he asks me if the biofilms can
be
removed
from the cages and that of course I mean
with sanitizing treatments and the best thing
is to sterilize what you mean
when you talk about u  A softener, the
warning lights, is the one that goes
through one, it is a softener, it goes through salts
and silica, and then what it does is
remove the minerals so that they do
not form and this and they can close the
valves or look for food, etc., it
softens the water,
thank you very much.  to those who are
sending me congratulations
this
I did my query is regarding the washing
of pipettes
allow me
well I thank
this for the compliments
I have recurring tonsillitis I have taken
several antibiotics I got the
procedure that would guarantee well
look the main thing is to make an
exudate and knowing what type of bacteria
You have to send the antibiotic to do a
very important antibiogram to know
that the antibiotic can attack you but
apart from everything now there are
very good products to do it that I don't know if they
are called the same in all countries but they
are gargles there is no intake and this
it makes like swishes and then throws it away because
that eliminates the biofilm
only the ozone does not guarantee the
stabilization of  l water so clear the
ozone kill everyone I tell you that in addition
to killing this everything that is
living and good and also inert
like viruses I
also told you that since it is oxidizing it
helps to remove magnesium herbicides
pesticides toxins many of these
bacteria  they die and since they have
endotoxin toxins at the time of death
they are released when they are ex or
toxins they are constantly releasing them
as they are like this
colleague no but when they are endotoxins they
have to die in the bacteria
bacteria to be released then
imagine that we  That is why we do not
kill the bacteria but it leaves us its
toxin, which is the most harmful thing. So if
this system is good,
ah,
when there is an otitis media infection
in rats, there is necessarily a loss
of balance. If
this system is generally affected, that
is, it is medium and then  it goes through
that there is growth and then
generally the damage is in the eardrum and
it is also characteristic you are
characteristic and rever  It is possible because
you can see that these animals
go to one side, that is, it is characteristic to
see the animals as they are, as well as
leaning to one side, it is typical of
an otitis.
What recommendations for the use of
quaternary ammonium?
biofilms well they are very
good or they are one of the best you admit
before that there is in this and it is said that if they
are in high concentrations they
even become cold sterilizers
then the ammonium quaternaries
kill not only bacteria and
viruses but also  They kill spores, which are much
more resistant. They kill
webó,
so it is highly recommended
as a sanitizer. Let's
see, this still gives me more time,
according to its presentation, we could understand
that the best water supply option
for rodents would be the one that says the one
of the one
of the ones.  bags well, it's that depending on
how much budget we ended up with, not because
I can't tell you that either because it
depends on the installations  tions and their
budget, what I want to tell you is that the
less process the
facilities have where humans intervene,
there is a guarantee that
the usual control of diseases will be easier, that
is, we are a
perfect family for infections,
this tells me  I have another question in
the pipeline, the biofilm has some color,
for example black coffee, thank you very much
because it also depends on the
bacteria, remember that there are
bacteria whose characteristic is not that they produce
sulfuric acid, others change the
color of the area for that reason  There are wounds
that look brown and others that look very
transparent,
these depending on the one in the throat,
it is a bacterium that has seen an end, it looks
transparent white as I present to you
then, depending on the type of
bacteria, it can also be like this, like
this,
the color  that can be formed because I think
I already have 47 seconds to
thank you, I do not thank everyone for being
with me
and praying  I win, I thank the organization and
I, the conference live has been a
fun experience, father, I have
also learned a lot to do
this, that is, it has been very, very cool to be able to
be with you and I hope they are useful.
I have my talk, by the way, if you
want to use it, the
You can copy it, you can see it as many
times as you want, and I'll
leave my email here in case you have
any questions or if I missed it, then
I thank you very much and that you have a
chance to catch up
and greetings from Mexico, by the way, a
beautiful and sunny day  Because I have seen that
the snow storms are falling on the poor
and that's why then,
well, greetings from Mexico,
beautiful and dear and sunny. Also,
thank you very much for your attention,
if you still do not leave, because I see that
I still follow people  that I do not
get to answer them because I will
gladly do it by email and I will
extend it more to the people who
asked me in this about the issues
that are  that some questions are still coming
yes
yes no